we'll end this evening with a reading
from the book of Karl
if you look at earth from space you see
a dot that's here that's home that's us
on it everyone you ever heard of every
human being who ever lived out their
lives the aggregate of all our joys and
sufferings thousands of confident
religions ideologies and economic
doctrines every hunter and forager every
hero and coward every creator and
destroyer of civilization every King and
peasant every young couple in love every
hopeful child every mother and father
every inventor and Explorer every
teacher of morals every corrupt
politician every superstar every Supreme
Leader every saint and sinner in the
history of our species lived there on a
mote of dust earth is a very small stage
in a vast cosmic arena think of the
rivers of blood spilled by all those
generals and emperors so that in glory
and triumph they could become the
momentary masters of a fraction of a dot
think of the endless cruelties visited
by the inhabitants of one corner of the
dot on scarcely distinguishable
inhabitants of some other corner of the
dye how frequent their misunderstandings
how eager they are to kill one another
how fervent their hatreds
our posturings our imagined
self-importance the delusion that we
have some privileged position in the
universe are challenged by this point of
pale light our planet is a lonely speck
in the great enveloping cosmic dark in
our obscurity in all this vastness there
is no hint that help will come from
elsewhere to save us from our sin
it's up to us it's been said that
astronomy is a humbling and I might add
character building experience to my mind
there is perhaps no better demonstration
of the folly of human conceits than this
distant image of our tiny world to me it
underscores our responsibility to deal
more kindly and compassionately with one
another and to preserve and cherish that
pale blue dot the only home we've ever
known
you